[Música]
es la última batalla por mario x después
de más de 40 días de asedio la destruida
ciudad portuaria está en una fase
decisiva podría caer en manos de rusia
en cualquier momento un asesor
presidencial ucraniano dijo que sus
fuerzas están sitiadas mariupol la
ciudad donde la muerte llegó bajo la
bandera rusa decenas de miles de muertos
el 90% de las casas destruidas
los soldados ucranianos están rodeados y
bloqueados
las tropas de moscú asfixian la ciudad
quien ha avanzado hacia el centro lo que
queda en el distrito industrial o fiscal
donde se refugian los soldados
ucranianos es la única zona que todavía
controlan el presidente ruso vladimir
putin dijo en una conferencia de prensa
con su homólogo bielorruso que la
invasión era inevitable y lo que está
ocurriendo en nuclear es una tragedia
pero alexander lukachenko lo dijo bien
no había otra opción era sólo cuestión
de tiempo
las desafiantes declaraciones de putin
se producen en el momento en el que el
batallón de azov una unidad paramilitar
afirmó que las fuerzas rusas lanzaron un
agente químico sobre la planta
siderúrgica de azov tal en un post de
telegrama afirmaron que los ciudadanos
habían caído enfermos pero que no había
heridos graves un asesor del gobierno de
mariupol confirmó que se había lanzado
algo en la zona a pesar de que un
portavoz de los separatistas pro rusos
había sugerido anteriormente que podían
estar en uso eeuu reino unido y
australia están investigando la
información no verificada de confirmarse
sería el primero uso conocido de armas
químicas por parte de rusia durante su
invasión de ucrania